jean-paul nascimento secrétaire national
crs unsa police
bonsoir jean paul nascimento merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous êtes d'accord avec ce représentant
des commerçants gérald darmanin a réussi
ce test première manifestation gilet
jaune pour lui oui le test aujourd'hui a
été réussi par contre il ya eu un petit
oman deux manifestants donc il faudra
voir dans les prochaines manifestations
si la nouvelle doctrine du maintien de
leur fera ses preuves qu'elle est en
quoi consiste-t-elle précisément cette
nouvelle doctrine expliquez nous en fait
la nouvelle doctrine la nouvelle
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
les crs elle l'appliquent déjà puisque
elle elle est rompue à ce genre à ce
genre d'activité puisque c'est les
professionnels du maintien de l'ordre
mais compagnies républicaines de
sécurité ce qui assez qu'il faut former
les les clés les autres services de la
préfecture de police au maintien de
l'ordre et le ministre de l'intérieur a
déclaré que des formations allaient être
faites avec les crs et toutes les forces
de sécurité en présence
alors il y avait effectivement beaucoup
de crs on voit sur ces images
c'est ce qui a fait la différence
aujourd'hui selon vous lors de toutes
les manifestations il y avait beaucoup
de force de forces mobiles beaucoup de
force crs aujourd'hui il y avait
beaucoup de forces engagées sur le
dispositif mais il faut quand même
se mettre enfin dire les chiffres il y
avait beaucoup moins de manifestants on
était à 2500 manifestants sûr par pas
mal de blagues donc quand même mais on a
réussi à gérer cette manifestation sans
trop de dégâts c'est la bataille des
chiffres
le ministère de l'intérieur dit
effectivement 2500 manifestants qui ont
manifesté aussi dans le calme pour la
plupart l'ont oui tout à fait mais après
c'est juste une frange de 200 à 300 une
traque gauche ultra droite black block
qui qui sont là pour en découdre avec
les forces de l'ordre et beaucoup
d'interpellations en amont aussi c'est
ce qu'on a constaté
c'est ce qui fait que ça peut se
dérouler dans le calme par la suite oui
tout à fait il ya des dispositifs qui
ont été qui ont été mis en amont dans la
périphérie parisienne pour pour elle
pour contrôler pour contrôler les ces
individus qui voulaient en découdre avec
les forces de l'ordre ne serait-ce que
les barrages sur des antennes des
contrôles routiers sur le réseau
autoroutier de l'île de france
alors c'est ce que déplore aussi les
manifestants ces contrôles systématiques
pour eux c'est une entrave à la liberté
de manifester
c'est ce qu'ils disent est ce qu'il n'ya
pas trop justement de ses contrôles et
ses interpellations parmi eux soutenu il
ya aussi quelques quelques dégâts
collatéraux
vous savez nous les fonctionnels et les
fonctionnaires de police
on est là pour que les manifestations se
passe en toute sécurité
on n'est pas là pour empêcher les gens
de manifester on est juste là pour
sécuriser les manifestants et les gens
qui sont autour
que pensez vous de ce retour des gis les
jaunes le samedi manifestation il
ont déjà annoncé qu'il va se reprend qui
vont se reproduire les semaines
suivantes
qu'en pensez-vous on sait que la police
est assez fatigué en tout cas d'être là
tous les week-ends
la police est déjà très fatigué ça c'est
certes ça fait des années et des années
que les compagnies républicaines de
sécurité les forces les forces de la
préfecture de police sont tous les
week-ends / / / / l'arbre sûr on va dire
sur sur sur la chaussée et c'est vrai
qui fatigue mais on est là pour répondre
un ascète à cette demande et on fera
tout pour que toutes ces manifestations
se passe bien et dans le contexte
sanitaire particulier qu'est là qu'est
la pandémie comment est ce que on gère
ce type de manifestation où beaucoup de
monde sont présents en même temps et pas
tous masqués mais là c'est toute la
difficulté
non nous on sait qu'on doit porter le
masque quand on est au service
n à la vue du public donc c'est un petit
peu même pour nous plus difficile à
gérer mais nous on est là pour maintenir
et rétablir l'ordre public après pour
pour ce qui est des gestes barrières
lors d'une manifestation c'est un peu
compliqué à gérer
alors il ya ces fameuses grenades de
désencerclement aussi qu'ils sont moins
moins dangereux selon gérald darmanin
elles ont été utilisées aujourd'hui
elles ont fait leurs preuves
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas eu à ma
connaissance que des grenades de
désencerclement ont été ont été projetés
donc je là dessus je peux pas vous
répondre
tous français c'est que c'est une
grenade qui ne grenat avec deux pieds
moins puissantes mais la détonation et
le sonore est toujours aussi puissant
mais on ne peut pas vous en dire plus
pour le moment
oui donc on verra pas de blessé en tout
cas déclarés pour le moment on attend
évidemment d'autres informations que
pensez vous du nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur sa nouvelle doctrine
apparemment est appréciée est ce que
l'homme est apprécié ce que la confiance
est revenue
oui je pense qu'ils essayent de rétablir
la confiance qui a été perdue il ya
quelques mois avec une entreprise avec
le prennent leurs prédécesseurs ministre
de l'intérieur je pense qu'on va dans le
bon chemin
maintenant maintenant on va attendre un
petit peu
merci beaucoup jean-paul nascimento
d'avoir répondu ce soir à nos questions
sur arte france